hier ist ein Mädchen mit türkischem
Hintergrund zu Tode gekommen erstochen
worden getötet worden und ein anderes
Schwert verletzt worden und wieder
geht's nur darum ganz schnell entweder
wie sich hinzustellen und sozusagen was
wir zu denken haben und wieder mit der
nazikäule zu winken macht bloß den Mund
auf dann hauen wir drauf ich rede
darüber und zwar habe ich gesagt in
Gedenken an Würzburg hey Gedenken an
Frankfurt in Gedenken an Ludwigshafen
und jetzt in Gedenken an Iller Kirchberg
in Gedenken an edge und in die denken an
jedem Menschen der in unserem Land durch
eine Politik mit zu Tode kommt die nicht
erkennt dass wenn man Menschen nicht
integriert sie nicht aufhängt einfängt
und vor allem indem man sie
unkontrolliert ins Land holt ohne zu
schauen welche Probleme sie schon
mittragen welche Gewalt oder welche
Kriminalität sie schon getragen oder ob
sie krank sind hier hin lässt und damit
die ganze Gesellschaft jeden Menschen
jede Kultur jeder Religion in Gefahr
bringt dieses kleine Mädchen könnte noch
leben